ultima parisiens ont par leur rentrée
scolaire et inflation avec le prix de
nos cantines qui risquerait bien
d'augmenter en compte cette inflation
est évidemment le pas se répercuter sur
le porte monnaie des familles alors pour
éviter que les parents d'élèves ne
paient plus cher une commune de la
seine-maritime vient de prendre une
décision plutôt inattendue
ce sera entrée ou dessert à les repas
seront donc moins copieux les enfants
devront choisir entre l'entrée le
fromage et le dessert le but alléger le
coût du menu et limiter le gaspillage
alimentaire alors si certains
comprennent cette démarche c'est mieux
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils enlèvent un
animal plutôt qu'ils ont plein de
charisme d'autres n'hésitent pas à la
critique et sur les réseaux sociaux
obligent et des enfants a diminué leurs
repas souvent le seul équilibrée de la
journée est une autre alors fromage
dessert vin mais restreint les menus
dans les cantines trouvez vous ça
scandaleux
ouais vous cela scandaleux c'est la
question que vous posez moi déjà
couverts remercier laurent bonnaterre
être avec nous aujourd'hui parce que
c'est pas évident de venir sur le
plateau c'est une quand même décision
qui est extrêmement controversée vous
avez fait énormément parler vous mais
vous êtes bien dans vos bottes dans vos
baskets dans vos mocassins italien et
vous nous dites moi j'ai pris cette
décision et je la respecte je vais la
respecter pourquoi d'abord merci de
votre invitation et c est normal qu un
peu hésité à venir mais je me suis dit
clients c'était quand même le moyen de
toucher beaucoup de monde c'est votre
votre force va merci vous dit qu'elle
est controversée cette décision elle est
controversée sur twitter peu dans les
médias ont pas à caudebec pas dans les
communes voisines je me suis beaucoup
baladé ce week end j'ai beaucoup vu de
parents d'élèves y aller les foires à
tout ce qu'il y avait les forums des
sports il y avait des faits sans les
villages cette histoire les utilise en
lien avec les parents d'élèves et les
parents d'élèves élus puisque les
parents d'élèves dans les écoles élisent
leurs représentants ont voté à
l'unanimité pour cette décision qui
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
caricaturer ne restreint pas le volume
de nourriture le volume de nourriture
reste le même c'est juste qu'au lieu de
se servir en cinq étapes on le sert en
quatre étapes dont il ya autant à manger
et s'est servi différemment et il ya une
étude qui a été faite sur la
consommation des français en général et
des enfants en collectivité plus vous
avez de plats plus vous avez de
gaspillage donc on revient à quelque
chose de plus simple et vraiment le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens on a
des tickets de cantine assez bas mais on
voulait maintenir assez bas parce qu'on
a une population assez modeste à
caudebec et on voulait le permettre de
mettre les enfants à la cantine parce
que y'a rien de pire que les enfants qui
ne vont pas la cantine parce que quand
ils vont parler cantine vous ne savez
pas ce qu'ils mangent il ya évidemment
des tas de familles où manger très bien
mais aussi des tas de familles ne vais
pas et dans précédent lorsque j'ai été
élu juge avait découvert qu'ils avaient
des tickets de cantine qui était
beaucoup trop cher et j'avais une
stratégie d'évitement sert des parents
qui ne mettait plus enfin la cantine qui
s'arrangera avec les grands-parents
examine et lorsqu'on a baissé à l'époque
de 1 euro le ticket de cantine on a
baissé le ticket de cantine des enfants
sont revenus aujourd'hui on sert 700
repas par jour plus de cent mille par an
et on a envie qu'il soit équilibré mais
atteignable pour les familles alors donc
ils ont reçu un jour pas de décès ou un
jour pas de l'entrée ou un jour pas de
fromage gilles souleymane vous êtes
est atterré et scandalisé avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour votre fonction et
pour vous même monsieur le maire vous
faites des économies sur le dos de nos
enfants et là c'est une honte et non je
n'ai pas dit que vous invoquez le
gaspillage alimentaire ça c'est la honte
des ondes c'est à dire que quand vous ne
savez pas comment vous en sortir vous
dites gaspillage alimentaire monsieur
pour des tas d'enfants la cantine c'est
le seul repas de la journée ils vont
vraiment manger voulait priver de
dessert ou les priver de fromage voulait
priver d'entrée mais comment un maire
responsable de ses co citoyen peut faire
ça monsieur le maire a le rangement
revenait sur cette décision je vous en
supplie alors déjà les codes beckenbauer
foot ils ne veulent
les habitants de caudebec les elbeuf qui
sont ceux auxquels je dois des comptes
ne me demande pas de parents d'élèves
élus que vous avez dû soudoyer
on attendait laurent de l'aide parce que
là arrête un peu dire des bêtises comme
ça monsieur le maire vient il va nous
expliquer pourquoi il a pris cette
décision tu viens dire des bêtises comme
ça qu'il a soudoyé des lèvres
insultant pour moi ça a tout le temps
pour
je reviens sur ce point précis vous avez
dit que j'allais faire des économies
mais non je vais pas faire des économies
parce que même cette adaptation la salle
s adressent à charge pour la commune
quel est le but alain on avait 32 mètres
c2c que le budget présenté le but c'est
que le budget tienne 6 à augmenter oui
cette année il n'y a pas de la cantine
qui augmentent pour les communes il ya
l'électricité et cirque ou du pétrole il
ya un coût du chauffage tout augmente
pour les communes en année normale on
l'aurait absorber cette hausse qui avait
eu que la hausse des cantines mais en
années difficiles on a tous qui augmente
et donc le choix qu'on a fait c'est que
l'augmentation qui était prévu de 32000
euros par an elle ne soit plus que de
25000 euros 27000 euros par an
exactement il nous reste cinq six mille
euros à notre charge donc d'un budget
augmente quand même et on ne fait pas
d'économies sur le dos de l'an est
énormément à réagir à cette décision
parce que je pense qu'il ya d'autres
communes un qui vont suivre comme à
chaque fois c'est à chaque fois ça il ya
une initiative qui est pays et après les
autres suivent c'est vrai que donc voilà
donc cyril oui il ya aussi beaucoup de
communes qui vont augmenter le prix des
cantines bien sûr et c'est une vraie
difficulté de direct chez les parents
puisque après vous avez par ailleurs d
un pays à l élan ne peut plus payer
alors guillaume moi je suis d'accord
avec souleymane encore une fois c'est
honteux ce qui se passe alors certes ça
n'a pas changé la vie d'un enfant d'être
privé de babybel à la cantine mais ce
qui m'énerve c'est qu'on en train de
culpabiliser les gens et ce dès leur
plus jeune âge c'est prend pas la
voiture prend pas l'avion prend pas deux
fois l'âge c'est à dire sans rien non
mais dès leur plus jeune âge et les gens
en général on est dans une ère où on
inventera de culpabiliser les gens pour
tous et les empêcher de vivre pour moi
c'est une sorte d' atteinte à la liberté
et ce qui m'énerve c'est qu'on passe
notre temps à être taxés surtout par
l'état et que dès qu'un peu d'inflation
c'est pas à l'état de payer mot français
qu'ils semblaient se serrer la ceinture
je trouve que c'est en train de
culpabiliser les gens et c'est pas bien
ah oui dans les gens et j'entends mais
j'entends monsieur le maire votre votre
argent' un loup le renard et la belette
il entend effectivement 32000 euros par
an en raison de l'inflation
d'augmentation du budget je n'entends
que effectivement sinon c'était plus de
7% d'augmentation du prix des cantines
ou l'augmentation des impôts d'accord
mais est ce qu'il n'y ait pas un
arbitrage différent à faire à ce qu'on
pouvait pas plutôt que d'aller jeu
décidez de d'être sur les cantines et
donc sur la nourriture de nos enfants
trouvé l'arbitrage ailleurs dans la
mairie et à imagine qu'à d'autres choses
mais on peut sur lesquels vous auriez pu
rogner mais madame on passe notre temps
à faire des arbitrages alors le but
n'est pas de rogner méplat sur les
enfants monsieur c'est le symbole qui m
importe le symbole il est très mature
vas-y le symbole est très fort ça veut
dire qu'au moment où il ya de
l'inflation au moment où ça devient
compliqué ce sont les enfants qui vont
commencer à en payer le prix en devant
faire des choix il est là un symbole et
puis je vous rappelle que vous
savez que c'est le symbole l'ordre j'y
tiens beaucoup et je vous rappelle aussi
le gouvernement k'bidi locaux vides
personne ne paiera on est en train de
payer et ça y est les enfants le paye
les enfants le paye vous demandez aux
enfants de faire un choix quelque part
mais sinon ils n'ont pas de choix les
enfants on leur fournit mais j'ai très
bien compris j'étais là mais moi j'ai
très bien compris il ya avant les années
v5 donc c'est eux qui se [ __ ] impayés
vous pouvez juste me donner deux mondes
pour vous donner deux trois éléments de
contexte complémentaires symbole les
enfants par ailleurs si on continue
parce que notre sujet ce qui aussi de
continuer à servir la gagne de la
qualité de la diversité alimentaire vous
savez dans beaucoup de familles pas tout
malheureusement les légumes sont pas là
tous les deux et c'est donc on sait
recéler goût là on fait des légumes
rares on essaie des choses qui marchent
mal d'ailleurs parce que les enfants ils
ont pas envie de manger c'est une vraie
difficulté on est tous pris dans la
contradiction de devoir servir que des
nuggets frites steak haché ou de
diversifier et quand on diversifie on à
du gaspillage et on en est les premiers
les premiers triste et celles qui en
sont plus tristes vais vous dire c'est
les dames de cantine qui jettent 14
tonnes de nourriture par an elles sont
vraiment tristes et elles ont vraiment
approuvé la mesure donc je alors un
élément de complément juste cyril un
élément de complément c'est que dans
notre commune et c'est pas du tout une
obligation et très peu de communes le
font tous les jours y ait un laitage
auquel j'ai une question à laquelle vous
l'auriez fait si elle pas eu pour cent
de l'inflation actuellement à bbb ce
moulin et ben voila l'enquêté dira que
c'est pour le choix vous êtes en train
de faire on a fait des victimes en ils y
apprennent d'argent et les enfants
doivent le payer mais la drac au départ
c'est des histoires d'équilibré
présentés soit la maison rey non pas sur
les enfants monsieur mais alors d'abord
je voudrais un montant dont je voudrais
jean michel maire mais je trouve les
questions de matthieu excuse moi mathieu
mais qu'on m'ait demandé de lui
évidemment s'y est pas la crise si
c'était l'abondance et l influence
évidemment on aimerait bien qu'ils aient
deux desserts trois desserts pas
n'importe pas de sens mais monsieur
laisse entendre que c'est pas à cause de
l'argent c'est justement pour éduquer
les enfants c'est dans un village d'une
réalité économique monsieur le maire est
obligé de gérer un budget qui est serré
c'est le même volume de nourriture ont
fait les choix de nombre d'aliments
c'est pour que tous les enfants puissent
continuer là c'est la porte ouverte à
d'autres choses mais bien sûr que si
mais bien sûr que si et en plus être
autre chose on suit sa trempe à limiter
le sport dans la commune on va limiter
d'autres choses aux enfants à chaque
fois qu'on prive une liberté et une
deuxième qui suit alors le 7 world en
plus ça coûte pas plus cher à jean
mallet non monsieur le maire je vous
trouve absolument incroyable c'est
dommage qu'ils croyaient pas le maire de
paris excusez moi vous êtes tous démago
sur plateau vous est dans le concret
d'abord on jet de 21 kg de nourriture
quoi on prend quoi ils doivent pas lent
qu'on les donne pas des gens parce que
dans les deux cas elles sont ouvertes
quand la barque est à l'époque n'avait
pas consommé de la drogue quand même de
la gueule a ouvert ou peu plus la donne
et la barquette et on était interdite
heureusement d'ailleurs bonjour cantine
les enfants iguchi chipote comme ça et
après on jette donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment la gabegie et c'est vraiment
horrible moi je trouve que c'est concret
vous avez un budget ont fait justement
ça pour pouvoir faire du sport à côté
pour pouvoir faire du théâtre des
ateliers des choses comme ça vous moi je
trouve que c'est pas très grave ne pas
avoir un bas de laine si on a une crème
dessert cap admin on n'y a pas mort
d'homme et tout ça il aurait fui
attendait j'étais là du fait des
restrictions aux questions qu'elle
soulève est un band y at-il de babybel
jours certains il ya l'état tous les
jours il y en a marre il y en a marre de
tout ce truc me dit l'inflation le
pétrole l'électricité les conflits dans
le monde non paye tous les conflits dans
le monde ont fait long feu et tout est
maintenant c'est les enfants et moi je
suis d'accord avec mathieu aujourd'hui
c'est ça après c'est fini l'abondance
finissent aussi on n'a pas appelé les
parents à venir
si l'ipad et vous allez être gâtés avec
moi sur le gardien
je vais parler à monsieur le maire
vous savez très bien que le gars ce cas
c'est pas juste une question de fromage
ou dessert ce que l'on ce concert la
plupart des sociétés je vais donner même
de notre société et les sociétés qui
livre les continents barquettes comme ça
dit c'est de la merde pas c'est
dégueulasse alors ceo c'est pour ça que
les enfants ne mangent pas et le
gaspillage y en aura quand même c'est
pas parce que vous enlevez le fromage et
le dessert qui aura pas de gaspillage
bernard a quand même les enfants ce
qu'ils prennent c'est le pain et le
yaourt et vous sait très bien que sur
100 repas sur son repas répondez moi
franchement sur 100 repas combien
finissent les assiettes combien
d'assaillants nuit plus sortiront bien
là cette mission d'étude qui s'offrirent
salle où venait de la qualité et la
raison mais le fromage et le dessert ça
veut rien dire les envies du sous vide
dégueulasse concentrez-vous sur la
qualité au lieu de la concentrer sur les
associations de service qui gère quatre
dates et les horaires que tâtonner la
solution de raymond ce serait de donner
moi mais plus qualitatif exactement je
prêtais de faire des remous dans les
budgets pour faire travailler des
sociétés qui vous font des repas à 20
centimes vous ouvrez la barquette c'est
dégueulasse voulait que j'en mette sur
les réseaux sociaux ce qu'ils mangent
nos enfants la plupart des gens ne
savent même pas ce que mangent leurs
enfants qui a dit à son enfant qu'est ce
tu as mangé à midi quand tu rends du
travail qui demande pascal est rejeté
ces griots renaudo tournedos papillotes
du barétous flautre
bah
letourneau de papillotes doré
il est bon crème brûlée un peu
d'habitude c'est un truc qui est
toujours alors levé laurent bonnaterre
je suis pas le porte parole de notre
prestataire il se trouve que notre
commune avant moi je sais pas quand
c'est et a renoncé à faire la cuisine
sur place je le regrette mais pour leur
mettre en place c'est absolument
impossible alors connaissez je reconnais
mais à moi les saynètes alors en
attendant après sa terre on a un
prestataire qui se trouve qu'il est bon
et je le sais parce que moi je mange
tous mémoire de tête je l'aï mangé tous
les mois la cantine et je vérifie donc
ma chaise mais la manche et tous les
mois la cantine tous les mois dans les
cantines des écoles cheggaf j'appréciais
gros titres qui de damien bouchard
ça le bonheur au moins ils mangent ou
soit par mathieu m'enverrait cantine la
bombe et redresse et revient vers
londres est à terre c'est un prestataire
et donne un nom qui fait la cuisine sur
place à 30 kilomètres de chez nous c'est
des grandes cuisines avec des
professionnels de la cuisine
si je pouvais faire mieux que prévu mais
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il ya des
moments où je gère le budget d'une
commune ça fait 14 ans qu'on n'a pas
augmenté les impôts dans la commune 14
ans qu'on n'a pas augmenté les impôts
vous conviendra alors c'est une très
bonne question merci de la pause et il
coûte entre 60 centimes pour les gens
les plus modestes et 3 euros 60 sa
saisie mois de romy et on redouble et
coûte combien leur part
3 sur 3 euros soit 100 défection de
questions sur cette très chère il mange
quand je vais citer des marques
personnes centime des mères les familles
les plus modestes oui les plus modestes
mais y'a pas que les plus modestes alors
c'est aux gens qui travaillent qui
payent la cantine leur niveau européen
geie fanti moi je travaille et c'est ici
mes enfants et amis ils devenus mari
chauffeur-livreur et la comptine heures
que je suis content perd 3,62 cantine si
ça peut aider quelqu'un capable
je dis qu'il ya des société sogeres sa
mort sodexo qui servent de leurs enfants
voient les poubelles mais mais c'est
comme ça c'est une réalité pour nous a
dit vous cherchez tu les écoutes a
indiqué justin le plus cher parce que
vous avez raison c'est un problème quand
c'est trop cher la sorte salaires
emblème il était à 4h50 ya quatre ans on
l'a baissé à 3 euros vous entre vous
mais y'a encore des corridas
d'accord mais d'accord voilà d'accord
mais y'avait commune à 4,50 et il y
avait comme une amende salée me dis
qu'est ce qui manque c'est toujours
plein et un yaourt maintenant si vous
voulez que fermer les yeux et dire c'est
bon nos enfants ils mangent super décor
qui nous fait nous elle devait commencer
le vrai problème oui ça c'est un
problème dans le mettez vous à 4 actions
moi je voudrais je voudrais dire un truc
en tout cas je le dit laurent en tout
cas il prend des décisions lorsque vous
dire il ya que les gars qui ne prennent
pas de décisions il prenne pas de
mesures qui font pas parler 2-1 et les
mecs qui font rien mais c'est vrai
risque forcément quand tu prends une
décision a battu créer des battues créé
la polémique au fond pas la polémique
mais tu vois des gens qui sont pas des
gens qui sont contre au moins lui il
bosse non mais c'est ça au moins on peut
pas lui reprocher de ne pas bosser et ça
c'est déjà fait pareil
mais il va manger avant tiny voit ce qui
se passe ils parlent de ce qu'ils
connaissent et ce à des gars qu'ils y
sont là pendant cinq ans ils vont ils
foutent rien sans forcément ils peuvent
décision oui justifie ses décisions les
b vous me reconnaître quand même que
vous avez baissé le prix que vous avez
réussi à juguler la hausse du prix en
privant les enfouis sous des serres donc
c'est l'ump monsieur le maire vous avez
bien réduit parce que vous dites les
quantités sont les mêmes noms il avait
bien réduit l'ampleur du repas pour
faire des économies il réduit un nombre
de portions mais l'ampleur du repas la
quantité la même monsieur et vous
mettrez trois frites de plus et ça
masque le truc
surpassée téléspectateurs si vous voulez
regarder ses 44 ans aston damon non à
55% laurent bonnart est ici d'avoir est
avec nous vers sion